so Eric we've taken some questions from
some viewers that have been willing to
leave them on our community table for
YouTube we have so many here and
apologies to those we don't get to one
of which is from Melissa rose and
Melissa Wright's is there one thing you
feel is essential for a screenwriter
slash writer to know before beginning
before starting well there are a lot of
things but I mean I think that the
reason I wrote this book about you know
making the idea process a priority is
really based on my feeling that you need
to know that choosing the idea that
you're gonna write is so important and
so essential and not easy to pick an
idea that's gonna be a worthwhile thing
to write worthwhile meaning it would
have a chance at you know moving you
forward in the industry it's always
worthwhile to write and have the
experience perhaps for yourself and your
own learning and growth but from a from
a commercially marketable can move my
career forward standpoint to meet the
part of the most important thing which
is why the you know I wrote this book
about this is is to understand what the
elements are of a viable story idea and
to make coming up with one your main
priority and take the time and get the
feedback necessary on your just ideas
before you launch into six months or a
year or even several years writing and
rewriting a script because you can write
and rewrite a script endless times but
to make it somewhat better but if it's
based on an idea that really was always
gonna have a tough time moving forward
no matter how you execute it a manager
and agent would call that somewhat
wasted time so that's probably my first
obvious self-serving answer based on my
book being about what makes sense maybe
we can go back to actually some more of
the words in this problem acronym so
original you know we hear so much of
that it's got to really have this
writers voice and all that and and and
got to be this fresh sort of but hasn't
so much already been done it seems like
it'd be very challenging today to have
something quote-unquote original it is
tough I think to be really original and
you know it goes back to your question
about writing things that are really
personal to you you know sometimes the
most original things do come from taking
your real life
or taking something you witnessed or
experienced and using that as fodder for
materials so there there is there can be
a value for that if you can also do what
I talked about which is find a way to
have perspective on it so you can make
it viable entertaining compelling to you
know millions of people that don't know
you it's not an easy thing to do but you
know originality is it's a tricky one
because you can only be so original
because if so many things have already
been done right so many types of stories
and genres and types of story situations
I mean I just saw eighth grade last
night yeah which you know it was a very
original voice but it's about something
that we've seen four million examples of
which is a kind of misfit teen who the
popular people are mean to trying to
find their way in the social universe of
school like is there anything that's
been done more often than that but yet
you watch the movie and because it felt
authentic and real and specific and
vivid and done not in exactly the way
we've seen it before and it had some
currency because there was a whole
social media aspect to it where she has
like a vlog and she's on Instagram all
the time you know it feels like it's
very much about that problem for today's
8th graders in a certain setting so you
update it you make a current you make it
specific I think that's the thing it's
not that it has to be an idea that is so
out there and different and special
because sometimes that can be a trap if
you try to be too original sometimes you
end up writing things that are contrived
or hard to believe or hard to understand
because your focus is on it has to be
different from everything else when a
writer focus too much on originality I
wrote in this book
sometimes they're doing at the expense
of these other important elements of
what makes a viable story idea like it
may not be as compelling or as
entertaining or as relatable or these
other things because they're mainly
focused on yeah but no one's ever seen
it before
doesn't matter though if no one's ever
seen it before if it doesn't grab the
audience or the reader and the ways that
great stories always have so you always
have to balance the need for originality
with those other elements that being
said you're right that an original voice
is highly valued in a new writer but
it's like finding a way to have that
I think Authentics a better word that
authenticity where things feel so real
so believable but so like well observed
and unique and we haven't seen it quite
this way before because something in
this writers way of seeing the world and
people came up with this version of it
that is very memorable even if it's
within the context of something that is
somewhat familiar you know like a like
if you look at Napoleon Dynamite in its
day kind of the same thing
very original voice but it's about an
awkward teen who doesn't fit in and
people you know push him into lockers
you know kind of thing but when you
watch it you're mainly focused on the
authenticity the originality of it not
noticing that this is a story form or a
genre or a type of story problem that
we've seen endless variations on before
so it's kind of like you're taking
something that's been done in terms of a
genre usually but you're putting a very
fresh unique current specific spin on it
right I'm I'm thinking of pretty and
pink so so that first sort of you know
our generation that was sort of the The
Misfits movie especially female
character and just what would that still
work today but yeah you add in the
vlogging element and I haven't seen
eighth grade that's on my list but
something where you know she's in this
sort of town and she sees like the sort
of the the Scioscia and I know
associated it's it really used these
days but and sort of that went looking
up and looking to aspire you know and so
I think anybody can relate to that
that's that's a universal thing but yeah
you throw in the vlogging element the
social media but yeah this sort of the
high school party that everybody cringes
that you go to and and and hope to be
noticed but you know they don't really
see you and you sort of blend into the
background type of a thing do you feel
that it's still possible though to do
that story over and over again I know
you said you've you've added in the or
they they've added in these new things
the the social media and the things that
are current today but that that story is
very universal whether it's male or
female
yeah I mean I I do I think it is
possible and bo burnham proves it with
that example that you can do this thing
we've seen so many times you can
simply call up other movies that have
that same component I mean it has that
high-school party that the character
walks in and is petrified and doesn't
get noticed or gets noticed in a
negative way it has that very scene but
it has a unique version of that scene
we've never seen before that feels real
and feels very well observed and is very
entertaining and emotional to watch so
to me that's the key thing don't try and
reinvent the wheel in terms of genre or
types of story problems but bring
something fresh specific real and
original to your treatment of that of
that sort of genre element that we know
is universally relatable because that's
one of the really hard things is to make
sure that what you're putting out there
is gonna be relatable to millions of
people and the kinds of stories
situations that are going to be have
probably been explored many times before
because there aren't an infinite variety
of them there are certain core elements
that you tend to see repeated over and
over again in successful stories that's
why I love Blake Snyder's tens on resent
the cat it's my favorite thing about
that book and I always work with those
10 John Roos when I work with writers
writing screenplays because I think he
really pinpointed like the kinds of
human situations that we've seen work
over and over again in successful movies
and there were variations on each but
there are certain key core elements that
are present to sort of realize which one
you're going for and then to really try
and fulfill its elements I think is a
really helpful tool for writers coming
up with ideas for films well so the last
letter in your acronym for problem is
meaningful
so taking let's say 8th grade or
Napoleon Dynamite or pretty-in-pink or
whatever in that sort of that high
school you know not fitting in genre
what would be what's the meaning that's
a movie like that could give because you
could just see it as well it's just yeah
hey everybody I had a tough in high
school doesn't matter if you were
popular it doesn't matter if you were
bullied everybody had it tough in some
degree so where's the meaning in that so
I think if you walk away going what
everyone had tough in high school what's
the big deal that means that movie
didn't affect you very much and it
probably wasn't meaningful to you right
so meaningful to me is when we talk
about like theme and what's a movie
really about underneath its its surface
plot
the message or what's the underlying
issue being explored or issues and also
what the audience takes home with them
do they feel impacted by do they feel it
had some meaning to their own lives as
opposed to I just watched these people
have this thing happen and I sort of
forget about the next moment or it
doesn't really nothing that I saw feels
like it impacts me in my view of the
world and people at all it's just a
fictional story and when it's over it's
very forgettable so meaningful in some
ways is the most optional of these seven
elements that I put in the book because
certain movies like let's say
transformers or something don't
necessarily to be need to be so
meaningful and have such a strong theme
like that and I'm not dissing
transformers or saying that it doesn't
have any theme or meaning but certain
kinds of movies if they're so
entertaining and they have such a
punishing problem that is relatable
enough to a universal audience which
when you have life-or-death stakes you
usually have that one covered you know
life-altering stakes what's the other
one original and believable if it's
executed in ways that do all those
things you could have a hit movie on
your hands even if it isn't that
meaningful but what most writers trying
to break in are trying to do our movies
that do have a lot of meaning because
that's often what writers are most
attracted to is the theme and the
character arc and that kind of stuff
that tends to give something meaning I
also think we talked about the
originality and the whole executing
something in a brand-new way that feels
very specific and well observed and real
that helps give it meaning to people
because if they feel like they're just
watching this contrived thing that was
just there to entertain them but it
nothing about it felt real or felt like
oh and my life and my kids or my memory
of childhood I can I went through that
or it like touches me then it's not
going to be meaningful to them so
meaningful is maybe the most optional
and the final one of the seven to
consider but it can be the most
important one in the end that like puts
you over the top because if your script
makes people really feel something and
almost makes them think about their own
lives in some way even as you know a
hardened professional reader in the
industry if it really makes them feel
like I didn't just watch these remote
people but I connected and it feels like
it explored something about the human
condition that's relevant to me and
everyone that's really powerful
you